Microsoft's CEO weighs in on the Xbox
PlayStation drama Modern Warfare 2 specs
for PC dropped and an update on the next
Splinter Cell game all this on today's
Gamespot news
[Music]
speaking with Bloomberg Microsoft CEO
Satya Nadella is confident that the
company's proposed
68.7 billion dollar acquisition of
Activision Blizzard will be approved by
Regulators the executive went on to
point out that Microsoft is not the
biggest player in gaming he estimated
that Microsoft is the number four or
number five player in the space with
Sony being first quote so if this is
about competition let us have
competition the Della said while this
statement is true acquiring Activision
would likely make Microsoft the biggest
games publisher and on top of that
Microsoft as a whole is a much bigger
company than Sony with a market
capitalization of over 20 times the size
nadella's comments come after the UK's
competition and markets Authority
launched a more extensive investigation
into the buyout the CMA said it is quote
concerned that Microsoft's proposal to
buy Activision Blizzard could quote
substantially lessened competition for
sales of game consoles subscription
services and cloud gaming networks but
forget about PlayStation and Xbox PC
gaming is the only way to fly you're
above the petty corporate squabbles all
you care about is Modern Warfare 2 specs
which dropped today along with the open
beta for the game on the platform if you
pre-ordered minimum specs for the beta
core 4 8 gigabytes of RAM and Intel Core
i5 3570 or AMD ryzen 5 1600x CPU along
with an Nvidia GeForce GTX 960 or AMD
Radeon rx470 card the recommended specs
meanwhile call for 16 gigabytes of RAM
and Intel Core i7 47 70k or AMD ryzen 7
1800x CPU and an Nvidia GeForce GTX 1060
or AMD Radeon RX 580 card basically if
you've built or bought a PC in the last
eight ish years you should be in the
clear find tuning your in-game settings
has also never been easier Modern
Warfare 2 has added some great
functionality such as customizable Quick
Settings menu and a settings search bar
a full list of specs and features can be
found on gamespot.com a game that likely
won't run on Hardware from 2014 will be
ubisoft's Splinter Cell reboot because
it became is not coming out anytime soon
that's because the publisher is still
hiring riders for the title in a job
listing that was spotted by PSU Ubisoft
is looking to hire a script writer who
can Faithfully update the original
game's story quote using the first
Splinter Cell game as our foundation we
are rewriting and updating the story for
a modern day audience the advertisement
reads we want to keep the spirit and
themes of the original game while
exploring our characters and the world
to make them more authentic and
believable this Series has not seen a
Mainline entry since 2013's Blacklist
after years of rumors Ubisoft officially
announced the Splinter Cell remake in
December last year and confirmed that
the Remake will be built from the ground
up using the Studio's Snowdrop engine
featured in its Tom Clancy division
games
and that is it for today's Gamespot news
are you going to be jumping into the
Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2 beta on PC
this weekend are you excited for another
Splinter Cell game to finally drop let
us know in the comments below and we'll
see you tomorrow for more Gamespot news
[Music]